hallo mein abend meine lieben freunde
diesen unfassbaren leisten rudi gibt's
ab dem ersten 12
heute soll es allerdings gar nicht um
diesen geilen wo die hier gehen sondern
um das ziel
sie spielen nach einem jahr endlich mal
wieder break out finde die mutter henne
das ist rätsel nummer 122 also das
rätsel wo mit meinem letzten video vor
elf monaten stehen geblieben waren und
wir müssen jetzt die mutter henne suchen
[Musik]
wo ist sie
du bist sehr guter rente tech tief
also ihr seht glaube ich schon an alle
die das spiel nicht kennen es geht darum
dass wir so kleine dumme rätsel lösen
hilft der ente wasser zu trinken ich
würde einfach mal sagen dass wir das
wasser nehmen das auf die
m10 vielleicht müssen wir allerdings
auch das wasser erst auf die sonne oder
wir müssen irgendwas mit den wolken
machen von wegen alle wolken
übereinander und dann
[Musik]
vielleicht müssen wir auch die wolken
einfach vor die sonne packen so
gefällt ist das thema so für mich
klatschen hier müssen wir rot und blau
zusammenmischen wenn ich hier
draufklicken oder irgendwie drüber
streiche geht es nicht vielleicht kann
ich mein handy schütteln das geht nicht
finger drauf halten dann schütteln geht
auch nicht wenn er oben drauf halten
dann
ich komme gut voran heute hilfe wo ist
mein regen also die braut sucht ihren
ring wir können auf sie nicht drauf
klicken sie hat das nirgendwo wir haben
hunde füttern einen hund vielleicht
braucht
das war ziemlich easy ich würde sagen
wir machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten rätsel mache das licht wieder
aus wir haben
[Musik]
ihr müsst euch überlegen ich habe locker
schon zehn brain of videos auf einem
kanal hochgeladen und ich habe immer
ziemlich lange gebraucht ich glaube
einfach dass diese elf monate pause von
diesem spiel mein gehirn so
zurückgesetzt haben dass ich jetzt
richtig gut damit machen wir weiter mit
dem nächsten rätsel wie oft wird 1
verwendet wenn man alle ganzen zahlen
von 1 bis 199 nieder
[Musik]
wenn das falsch ist dann schmeiß ich
mein handy weg
es muss gegen was in die richtung sein
vielleicht 138 oder so vielleicht habe
ich mich auch irgendwie verzählt einmal
zu
437 und
hat das hatte ich mit 940
[Applaus]
grill den fisch für die katz
normalerweise würde ich jetzt einmal den
fischen und grillen
[Musik]
ich darf mich lange genug darauf lassen
also erst mal so ein bisschen warm
werden lassen und jetzt
[Musik]
da wir machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten rätsel jag vill saft trinken er
damit nimmt saft
sagt ja dass das nicht funktioniert
müssen wir erst mal irgendwas schütteln
müssen wir die kohle erstmal weg packen
es gibt auch nicht wohl mit saft mission
nesat erstmal aufdrehen vielleicht
schütteln
warum uns einen tipp können tipps
schütze ihn bevor du ihn ich
habe schon geschüttet aber
wahrscheinlich muss ich das ding nehmen
ich muss wieder reinkommen dass man ein
bisschen bedenkt was kleine häschen ist
erneut hungrig okay also wir müssen das
hinziehen wieder vor bewegen und dann
springen das gibt nicht
auf den kopf bringt auch nichts
[Musik]
irgendwas auf anklicken
bauen
und dann springt er sich darüber
[Musik]
ach so
er hat aber gerade zum er hat katze und
den gegessen das heißt theorie
dieses spiel ist um punkt
es gibt 26 buchstaben im alphabet wenn
et gegangen ist wie viele buchstaben
sind noch übrig lustigerweise
[Musik]
oder geht es um das wort alphabet dann
haben wir nur noch alpha dann haben wir
noch sechs hlp hbs müssten sechs
gegangen sind wie viele buchstaben 60
[Musik]
ich weiß jetzt einfach ein bisschen
runtergegangen aber keine ahnung warum
21 jetzt richtig war klasse alle
glühbirnen aufleuchten ich kann hier
draufklicken und dann
[Musik]
nicht in sicht
er ist so dumm das nicht klappt nur ob
man einfach das aus dem bild heraus was
nicht eine kerze ist 50 cm hoch und kann
drei stunden lange brennen eine weitere
ist 70 cm hoch und kann sechs stunden
lang brennen wie lange dauert es bis die
beiden kerzen die gleiche höhe erreichen
oh gott wieder mathe
[Musik]
das macht ja keinen sinn wenn die 70
zentimeter hohe kerze sechs stunden lang
brennen kann dann ist sie logischerweise
weil sie ja gleich schnell brennt die
ganze zeit brennt nicht erst schneller
habt dann langsamer ab dann ist sie wenn
sie nach weg sturm auf null ist nach
drei stunden auf 35 zentimeter und nach
drei stunden die eine kerze ja schon
besser ist logischerweise falls die
zeitangaben stunden ist dauert es sechs
stunden weil das wichtig weil beide dann
auf null sind erst an höhe also machen
direkt weiter kannst du das lösen ich
hasse sowas
[Musik]
ich gehe einfach alle zahlen durch
männer zählen dahinter
[Musik]
juni
braucht mich nicht daumen hoch da lassen
oder abonnieren oder blogger aktivieren
weil youtube nicht mehr lange alter bin
ich wissenschaftler hilft dem baby
einzuschlafen da würde ich eigentlich
einen rudi empfehlen außen haben ja
shop.de
[Applaus]
ich habe gerade noch gesagt du dir
empfehlen außen und dann lukas schott
damit ich selber im schnitt weiß dass
ich da die anwendung sein papa aber das
war jetzt das das war jetzt des rätsels
lösung dass sich hier so gesungen habe
perfekter 17 uhr podcast aufnahmen jetzt
herzlich willkommen auf meine man kann
hier wird präsentiert groß geschrieben
an der stelle ich das heute wieder jetzt
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch endlich mal wieder break out mit
luca gefallen lassen einen daumen hoch
unter dem video abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr weitere
videos nicht verpassen wollte morgen um
18 uhr kommt eine neue episode minecraft
mit luca raus wo wir etwas geiles in
unserem werk bauen werden also verpasst
das auf keinen fall und wenn ihr diesen
heute gern haben möchte dann schaut im
[Musik]